all right today's topic Johnny Depp and
Amber Heard are going at it in court if
you aren't aware the director has been
married to Amber Heard for quite some
time and then they're getting divorced
and it's been a messy Affair we've
covered a few videos which I'll link
below two years ago before yeah two
years earlier that we covered that now
they're in a lawsuit John tips taking
her to court and so it's been all over
YouTube people been asking us to cover
it some of it we've already covered so
we're gonna do a quick recap and then
we're gonna go to some of the new stuff
which I think is crazy and some of the
tidbits that I've heard that really
surprised me the thing and you figure in
the face and you said no I didn't what
the [ __ ] are you talking about
but I was hitting you it was not
punching you babe you're not punched
don't tell me what it feels like to be
punched that audio never fails to still
sound so [ __ ] up it's [ __ ] up I
don't care who it was that was saying
that [ __ ] I didn't punch you I hit you
what what does that make it better
I didn't punch her face I hit your face
no it's the
I'm sorry that it hit you across the
face with a close fist like
I didn't I didn't the minimization of
all the stuff that you did yeah I did
start a physical yeah you did so I had
to get out of there yes you did you did
the right thing the big thing the you
know you're admirable
you might not even realize
my [ __ ] up behavior is real
responsibility to fix
so when I'm hitting you and putting my
hands on you gotta help me stop
all right it's gonna turns really
because this can turn really quickly in
light yo look what you make me do
you make me do these things and then
when it happens you Don't Stop Me Now
Jesus
won't explode if you just do the things
a little different in the fight you know
like don't walk away from me do it in a
different way and I promise I won't
resort to the same [ __ ] I promise this
is so controlling it's like don't walk
away don't leave the only kind of power
that a man has these kind of situation
is to remove a belt from it she's trying
to take even that away don't leave don't
walk away from me don't leave
do it my way
and we can fix it
[Music]
see what the jury judge thinks tell the
world Johnny tell them Johnny Depp I
joined that man I'm I'm a victim and I
you know it's a fair fight it seems how
many people believe or besides of you
believe victims
believe them and as a victim that was
recorded
and there's still doubt about whether or
not she did it
it doesn't matter if it's a fair fight
exactly
you're a bit you're bigger and you're
stronger
you believe you believe it
this girl cut off a piece of his finger
yeah and said that's invalid because
he's bigger and stronger yeah
so I'm good today
well if you would have caught me with
this [ __ ] a couple years back I
would have lost my mom do you believe
do you believe you used me physically
do I physically believe I mean do I
believe yes
do you know I'm 115 well not anymore but
I was 100. let's just divert the
conversation so because you're under 115
you can never be an abuser never
that's what it is
150 pound woman in New York I had the
capacity of you that's not the question
that's not the question
and say she started it really I have
never been getting overpowered you
that's the difference between me and you
why did you try
another jury and the dogs will see is
that there is a very big difference
between me and you what fascinates me is
that as a woman's children stays
how she's perceived she understands how
so she feels like she got a [ __ ] blush
to do whatever well she's an actor it's
not like she's just unaware she's a
hundred percent aware about the
perception and she uses it to Advantage
yes
she's an actress and we call that a
casting
what you mean knowing what you look like
and what you portrayed it's casting so
you're cast in a role so yes of course
her primary job is to understand her
Casting you know what I was just
realizing as I'm listening to this I'm
not mad I'm not upset I'm not bothered
I'm just like
it's tired yeah I'm tired I've seen this
in my whole life I haven't heard it for
women in person I hear from folks online
we covered it a few times I did my
yelling now I just hear it I'm just
resigned to it it's just the reality of
the world I got a message this is what
it is this is like
this is a reflection of every single
time
I'm
every single time
no one felt comfortable at putting our
hands on me
and I just
you can't do nothing
and you see the way the world looks
and doesn't say nothing and this is the
embodiment of that
that's what this is
so you know
after years of dealing with that anger
or being upset about certain experience
like you just after a while you come to
a certain level of acceptance and you're
you're like you can't change it so
you're just like what do I do don't want
to stay angry and ignorant about it
that's tiring
and so that's why I think about when I
hear these clips I just get tired and up
until that point in time did you hear
anything that led you to believe I've
got a crime they've been committed I did
not so this is a police officer
responded to Amber heard's called for
9-1-1 in regards to something
violence happening inside the house uh
by Johnny Depp against her so the police
officer the woman who showed up she's
testifying in court
did you see anything
to believe that a crime has been
committed I did not
stop people that aren't in time did you
hear anything that made you believe that
there had been an act of domestic
violence there I did not
to that point in time did you see
anything that made you believe that
there had been an act of domestic
violence there I did not
okay okay open till that point in time
uh did you ask Miss heard what happened
yes I did
and what was her response
no response she was uncooperative
and by uncooperative does that means
that when you asked her a question she
wouldn't say a word and she'd say
something that made you think she was
not cooperating she said we didn't say
anything
the cop didn't see any physical bruises
on her that indicate anything no signs
of any violence against her
but just to declare you would ask
questions and she wouldn't say anything
correct
but I asked the questions to establish
if there was some sort of crime
who was involved and again she wouldn't
give me any information I asked I
attempted to ask her friend
uh The Other Woman in the room right
even
us the males to wait in the hallway so
we could just be us women in there so we
could talk privately maybe she felt more
comfortable that way
still the denied that there was any
crime they wouldn't answer
any specific question so this is a
psychologist who interviewed Amber Heard
the results of misheard's evaluation
supported two diagnoses borderline
personality disorder and histrionic
personality disorder one of the primary
things I learned was that she had a very
sophisticated way of minimizing any
personal problems some of the primary
characteristics and I'm going to try to
condense 25 Pages here were essentially
externalization of blame
uh tending to have a lot of inner
hostility that is attempted to be
controlled
um a tendency to be very self-righteous
but to also deny that self-righteousness
and to judge others these people might
have that anger kind of explode out at
times they tend to be very passive
aggressive
they may be self-indulgent very
self-centered
they could use manipulation tactics to
try to get their needs met very needy of
attention acceptance approval
um
they tend to distance people who are
close to them initially they may seem
very Charming they're very socially
sophisticated actually that was a major
component on there they can react
violently they can react aggressively
they will often physically prevent their
partner from trying to leave if their
partner wants to get space
so hot day is someone who had BPD
unmedicated didn't take care of her
problem
this is exactly all of that
exactly all that only difference is
unlike Johnny Depp I didn't marry her
and I'd stick around to see more
nonsense okay well this is exactly it
some people who have this and are bad
folks they'll do [ __ ] like this
so am I surprised by this diagnosis not
at all it's literally what I expected
from everything I could hear and the
thing that happened is that
people think it's it's an actor thing
it's not an actress thing it's a high
profile because we know them yes yeah
but this is more prevalent than you
think this is more present in society
than you think
okay
it's okay it's normal that there's
people with
those mental issues
and it's out there
it is part of society
it is part of the norm the problem is
that a lot of people are undiagnosed
and they just like that they don't even
know it
these people are there so whenever
don't think that it's something that is
it's just something that just happened
once and it's not the no it's out there
it is there most of the time people
don't record most of the time it is not
high as high profile so we never hear
about it but that happens and most of
the time people do not have the means to
then fail and defend themselves like
that into court especially if they
didn't think about
recording
dear altercation so
this is a weird thing right folks will
ask why would Johnny stay with this
woman seeing this all the years
considering she has a past of doing this
to other folks why
here's the weird thing about deeply
flawed people okay
when you're deeply flawed yourself but
in a different way Johnny in this case
was an addict got mental issues himself
I'm sure right
he sees her who's in need
in the weird ups and downs that you
participate in become addictive in and
of themselves the highs become the
highest and the lows become the lows you
want to know why the highs become the
highest because when you go solo when
you look up at the summit you're like
damn I'm in this Valley we getting up
there whoo it's even better but when the
highest when the lows are so low the
highs are reward yes that's the thing
right so where most of us are here maybe
just [ __ ] doing this feel like
they've achieved much more even when
they're starting at a much lower point
it's like a it's a weird Loop you feel
much more satisfaction more involvement
more emotional connection because you're
dealing with so much extreme
it becomes highly addictive you get
pulled in pulled out that's how people
get stuck in these Cycles you don't have
to go really that far you've ever heard
about uh makeup sex that's the same
model no it's the same thing sure how
the makeup sex was so good because the
low was so low yeah so it's rewarding
and then your body ends up releasing
dopamines and this and that and whatever
and the third so it becomes addictive
you you get addicted to the feeling of
taking someone from the worst point and
bringing them to their highest but when
they're so often going like this with
borderline you're just constantly in
Loops I have to pull myself because I'm
like wait I had to take a third person
opinion but this [ __ ] looks crazy my
brain can feel it but like my heart
somewhere else I'm like oh hell no this
I was getting sucked into uh it's like
quicksand the more you try to the move
the yeah and the thing that happened is
that if you were not involved in that
situation you probably see things in a
different way because when you wouldn't
have been as as invested right yeah so I
understand how you can stay in that kind
of thing for so long especially when you
see yourself as flawed and you're like
if I help this person they can help me
with my flaws in a way there's
definitely that reciprocal energy so
this is some of the maybe the mindset
potential I can't say for sure do a
little throwback uh to um a classic
moment and I never think about myself
that way I never defend myself that way
I never see myself as a victim
in which I used to live
one that reminded me that despite all
that I had done and fought for all I had
said and survived before and through my
very public heart-wrenchingly lonely
battle for justice that I
a woman
would never truly see it as she's saying
this
you have to understand that she actually
believes what she's saying
she believes that that she believes it
that my voice didn't
couldn't
fully count
that despite what it took for me to
stand up and finally raise my voice and
to speak my truth my truth isn't that
the worst sentence to come out of an
abuser the last decade one of the My
Truth
people just use that to it's not fine
whatever
no no [ __ ] what happened you cutting
[ __ ] finger off that's what you
did
but my truth no no no
that's not show truth yeah
there's there's my truth his truth ain't
the truth and somewhere generally he's a
little bit more in the middle but
anyways let's keep playing it didn't
really matter
the deck was slacked against me in ways
I couldn't even begin to imagine is she
reading poetry
that's a blast from the past ain't it
is she reading poetry the doctor hold on
that would mean I said hold on yeah
but but she has the same like vernacular
and way of talking as someone that's
where I'm about I was about to do this
this is what happens when uh actors try
to sound deep and insightful yeah they
always sound like that yeah whenever
actors take up social justice they stop
corny like this I'm gonna say
it's funny she's saying that she's
saying like the the the the the deck was
stacked against me
in a previous recording she goes on to
say if you go in front of a judge and
say this stuff who do you think is going
to believe you Johnny who in the world
is going to believe
[Music]
that I'm I'm a
victims how many people believe or
besides of you so she's talking about
the the deck is stacked against her
meanwhile she's literally telling Johnny
Depp who's gonna believe you
do you think you have a chance
it's just it's interesting it's believe
her not Johnny I
ate
eight
steps
I would be met instead with hostility
skepticism and shame yes [ __ ] yes enough
is enough time's up me too Our Lives
matter
it is worth fighting for a world where
things are better where things are more
fair for everyone except Johnny
that's really what the whole trial is
fair for everyone except Johnny because
Johnny Don loves everything and nobody's
really talking about it the way they was
talking about it when he was Amber that
was being suffering now with Johnny
people watch but hey
it's not as loud you know I see yeah the
apology is not as loud as the disrespect
it's not but it's okay Carry On okay wow
with all this evidence all this footage
all this audio tape all this other stuff
she's still doing movies
yes was it wasn't she on the cover of
L'Oreal the other day she was she was
she was she was yeah she was a
spokesperson for the real or some [ __ ] I
was like God damn
you lost me like I said this probably
the last video I'll do unless there's
like a verdict that's crazy but
uh I'm just tired of this [ __ ]
I know Johnny's tired of this [ __ ]
because he's been married to her I just
seen her for three videos and I'm tired
what do you mean you heard too much
about her
don't encourage me Hey listen listen
don't encourage me listen preach comedy
skills missing Amber Alert
I'm only good because I didn't see a cup